henri ménudier bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin en direct sur la matinale
d'air france alors donc réunion
aujourd'hui à berlin entre les
représentants allemands et les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques à ce que
l'allemagne a réellement la possibilité
de faire pression sur les laboratoires
oui peut certainement faire de pression
mais la réunion d'aujourd'hui est de
toute façon assez compliqué d'une part
il faut qu'il y ait un accord entre les
16 länder
ce qui est pas facile ensuite il faut
qu'il ya un accord entre les länder et
l'état fédéral
et c'est seulement s'il ya cet accord
que de commencer avec les avec les
entreprises
alors le reproche qui est fait
effectivement sur ces retards de
livraison et fédérales comme les
gouvernements régionaux s'appuie sur les
accords qui ont été signés avec des
engagements précis et le dédain mais les
entreprises soient toujours eu répliqué
qu' il est indiqué aussi dans ses textes
que il les entreprises feront que leur
possible or étant donné le nombre
extrêmement élevé
le vaccin qui doivent être délivrés il y
à des problèmes techniques de
fabrication de distribution
hélas la justice peut difficilement le
condamner les entreprises ce qui bien
que je pense pas que la réunion
d'aujourd'hui bas portés va changer
radicalement la situation
l'allemagne a pris énormément de retard
dans sa stratégie de vaccination par
rapport à ce qu'elle avait prévu
initialement
elle est entré dedans d'ordre en
allemagne et situations qu'ils disent
est compliquée sur le plan pandémique
est en effet les länder de l'est qui
étaient les plus atteints ont tendance à
plutôt à aller dans le bon sens je veux
dire que le coronavirus d'après de
reculer mais dans les autres länder
il est surtout à l'ouest il ya soit une
situation de stabilité ou bien il y a
il ya une autre russe vous voyez que la
situation n'est pas facile d'en haut
c'est à dire que on a vacciné d'abord
les personnes âgées qui privés dans des
foyers et ensuite on a rouvert sur plus
de quel sens 445 de vaccins avec pas
prioritaire une les personnes âgées de
plus de 80 cents et le personnel
soignant il reste encore beaucoup à
faire et le gouvernement est sous
pression
aussi pour des raisons si vous voulez
une purement tic
étant donné qu'ils ont donc mois de mars
deux élections régionales importantes à
l'ouest etc en fonction de ces résultats
sera désigné le candidat à la
chancellerie qui devrait succéder à
grammaire que vous voyez que au delà des
aspects purement techniques
il y a aussi cette dimension politique
qui joue un rôle important
alors l'allemagne qui a par ailleurs
décidé de négocier aussi avec la russie
un pur à propos du vaccin spoutnik v
pour d'éventuels importations sait où
est ce qu'on en a aujourd'hui elle n'en
parle quand le ministre s'est chargé de
la santé a fait cette déclaration il
s'est référé non seulement aux vaccins
russe mais également d'actions chinois
la condition pour les utiliser c'est
qu'il y ait la corde l'union européenne
rp il faut qu' il y ait cette
autorisation au fond au niveau européen
pour faire rentrer les vaches russes et
chinois donc c'est aussi une façon de
mettre la pression et d'abord à toi et
jusqu'à maintenant fournissent les
vaccins merci beaucoup et en résine pour
votre éclairage ce matin je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur honoraire à la
sorbonne et spécialiste de l'allemagne